[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport encore un programme très chargé ce
soir on passe tout de suite au
sommaire de dans 3 jours sera donné le
coup d'envoi de l'Alstom Open de France
2014 au Golf National l'heure est au
dernier réglage sur un parcours qui sera
plus spectaculaire en vue de la Rider
Cup 2018 pour sa deuxè manche le Fit
Days faisait étape à 50 ans en Eveline
ce tour de triathlon qui permet aux
amateurs de côtoyer les meilleurs
mondiaux de la discipline ce weekend la
colline d'élancours accueillé la 15e
édition de la revancheard 6e et dernière
étape du VTT tour et ils étaient près de
160 à défier le point culminant
d'île-de-fance contre-rendu à suivre et
comme d'habitude en fin d'émission
l'essentiel des résultats du weekend
mais vous l'avez vu exceptionnellement
je n'ai pas le costume habituel pour
soutenir l'équipe de France les Bleus
qui affronte en ce moment le Nigéria
pour le compte des 8e de finale de la
Coupe du monde d'ailleurs nous
retrouvons notre envoyé spécial Olivier
Manis calco dans un bar vcinois à la
mi-temps mais tout d'abord place à notre
page spéciale
rugby après une saison blanche de
victoire en honneur on en a parlé hein
c'est sur ce plateau l'équipe senior du
Sky rugby a connu la relégation et donc
nouveau départ et nouveau staff et pour
parler de ce nouveau cycle le président
lionel garig est présent sur le plateau
du 7 sport bonsoir à vous vous êtes
accompagné de d'un des nouveaux
entraîneurs d'un des trois nouveaux
entraîneurs Guillaume paayen bonsoir à
vous merci d'être là tous les deux alors
tout d'abord Lionel je me je me tourne
vers vous après cette saison très
difficile il faut le dire he zéro
victoire en en honneur l'essentiel c'est
de de reconstruire à cette heure-ci
c'est exactement ça oui je pense que on
a fait on a fait subir l'équipe première
sans doute la plus dure saison sportive
qu'ils ont passé depuis la fusion du
club donc depuis depuis 4 ans révolu
maintenant
euh saison blanche saison noire saison
noire au niveau des résultats ça c'est
pour l'équipe première c'est vrai que
les résultats du club ne se ne se voit
pas seulement à l'Ô de l'équipe première
mais il faut reconnaître que c'est quand
même notre équipe Fagnon est ouais il y
a beaucoup de travail he derrière
évidemment sur les catégories jeunes il
faut pas il faut pas l'oublier et donc
du coup vous avez choisi de de prendre
un nouveau staff et un staff plutôt
familial puisque deux fils et et leur
père avec avec Guillaume qui qui est
l'un des représentant pourquoi cette
décision président euh effectivement il
fallait rebondir il fallait il fallait
donner un nouvel un nouvel essort au
club c'est c'est un phénomène classique
qu'on qu'on retrouve dans le sport euh
après cet échec après euh après avoir
subi tous ces tous ces toutes ces
défaites il fallait effectivement donner
un nouveau sens au club parce que nous
gardons toujours notre notre ambition de
rester un club représentatif de de 50 an
en yelin et que notre seule ambition
c'est de de remonter immédiatement en
honneur de de de de positionner le club
comme un club phare toujours sur c50s
Eveline compte tenu de des aspects
économiques que comporte le pôle le pôle
de Saint-Quentin cont de de de de toute
la population qui existe là nousous
c'est un devoir pour nous de représenter
Saint-Quentin euh ça n'est pas faire
offense à aux entraîneurs qui ont qui
ont on officié par le passé ils ont fait
un un travail très courageux et les
joueurs d'ailleurs ne se sont jamais
démobilisés pendant toute la saison ils
ont pris des défaites coup sur coup mais
jamais non plié jamais non plié ils ont
respecté l'adversaire ils ont respecté
le rugby tout simplement les valeurs du
rugby pour ça je les remercie et je les
remercierai jamais assez mais il fallait
leur redonner confiance cette confiance
elle sera incarnée par Guillaume son
frère et son père oui votre frère Thomas
et votre père Christian comment s'est
passé la prise de contact pour prendre
en main cette équipe première Guillaume
alors on a déjà Lionel nous avait nous a
rencontré au préalable pour nous faire
confiance et puis derrière nous
rapidement on a voulu avant d'attendre
le mois de septembre parce que c'est
très très loin euh voir les joueurs que
les joueurs nous voient et donc donc on
s'est
rencontrer par téléphone déjà et au mois
de mai on a voulu faire une journée
d'entraînement donc on a trouvé
le jeudi 8 mai on a fait un entraînement
en matinée les joueurs étaient étaient
assez assez incertains pour certains sur
le nombre qu'on allaitêt au moment de
centraînement puis finalement on s'est
régalé on était 45 à jouer à 10h du
matin et donc on c'est vraiment régaler
ça a permis aux joueurs de peut-être
être rassuré par rapport aux entraîneurs
qui arrivaient et puis ça nous a permis
à nous aussi d'être rassuré par rapport
aux joueurs qu'on avait av vooir et et
au fait que bah on arrive dans un club
qui a que des défaites l'an passé on
connait pas pas très bien les joueurs là
on a été rassuré directement c'estàdire
que on aurait pu sortir la tête dans le
saut le 8 mai non non on est sorti bien
content le 8 mai et on est rentré chez
nous très content très motivé et en
ayant hâte d'être au mois de septembre
justement au moment de la reprise quel
va être le discours du staff pour
essayer de remobiliser encore plus
l'effectif et puis de repartir vers des
ambitions de montter déjà on a com on a
vu les joueurs donc aussi le lundi
dernier pour essayer de leur leur mettre
un peu les les jalons du début de saison
parce que ça va être très rapide le
premier match étant le 21 septembre
c'est tôt pour le rugby c'est avancé
cette saison et donc donc il va falloir
être opérationnel très très vite donc on
les a mobilisé très vite aussi et et
voilà l'idée c'est l'idée c'est premier
objectif l'objectif général c'est
d'aller monter de remonter tout de suite
en honneur comme disait Lionel mais le
premier objectif c'est d'aller gagner le
premier match le 21 septembre on sait
pas qu' qui on sait pas à quel endroit
on sait pas si on sera à domicile
extérieur mais les joueurs sont on déjà
le premier contrat entre les mains c'est
première victoire et on passe bcule sur
autre chose on bascule vraiment sur
autre chose il y a les nouveaux
entraîneurs il y a les nouveaux visages
il y a peut-être des nouveaux joueurs
avec les juniors sur lesquels on compte
beaucoup les joueurs actuels nous ont
témoigné de leur soutien et leur volonté
de faire repartir sur une bonne
dynamique le club donc c'est
parti très motivé pour attaquer le 21
septembre par une victoire voilà
exactement alors par rapport à ce à ce
nouveau staff j'imagine que quand il y a
des têtes qui changent à la tête d'une
équipe il y a toujours un petit peu de
changement aussi dans la philosophie de
jeu en tout cas les principes de jeu
est-ce que vous avvez z imprimer votre
empreinte sur ce groupe déjà Parah par
rapport au jeu ouais peut-être sachant
que moi personnellement je peux me
permettre de juger totalement ce qui a
été fait par le passé j'ai été voir
seulement le dernier match où il est
tombé les trompes d'eau et où bah
franchement j'ai vu des bonnes choses
aussi même si le club enfin l'équipe
avait lâché je sais pas si c'est ces
imag là qu'on voit mais je
croisâ en tous les cas le match avait
été vraiment serré et ça avait craqué à
la fin du match et on espérait être
porte bonheur en disant on vient voir un
match une victoire ça serait top
finalement à la fin on avait craqué mais
voilà sur le jeu en début de saison on
va on va voir nous on sait sur quoi on
veut aller maintenant ça dépend aussi
des joueurs qu'on a on n pas vu tous les
joueurs en action et puis et puis voilà
mais l'idée c'est déjà de retrouver un
collectif fort soudé qui donne à 100 %
et qui tourne pas à 60 % à 70 % voilà
faut que les mecs soient vraiment dans
le truc direct pour pour être à 100 %
qu'on sorte du match gagnant gagnant
défait bah on sera plus content si on a
gagné que si on a perdu mais mais en
tous les cas on sera content par parce
qu'on aura tout donné on aura joué en en
équipe mouiller le le maillot come on
dit et alors du coup avec ce cet aspect
justement familial de frères et leur
père j'imagine que ça va être une force
pour vous de de vous retrouver tous les
trois au niveau de la cohésion du
discours par exemple peut-être on est
persuadé on en est vraiment persuadé et
c'est dans ce sens que j'avais fait la
proposition à Lionel de de venir avec
avec Thomas et avec avec mon père
Christian clairement simplement je pense
que beaucoup de personnes le comprennent
on va pas aller par qure chemin pour
dire les choses on va aller droit au but
on va voilà on va être efficace on va
gagner du temps le discours avec les
joueurs il sera pas il sera il sera
identique c'est que le joueur il a
parler à Thomas il a parler à moi il a
parler à Christian ce sera pareil donc
voilà on va gagner du temps je pense
avec ça et c'est important aussi pour
pour les joueurs voilà de retrouver ce
un cadre qui qui permet d'avancer et
d'être efficace aussi parce que c'est un
pe un minimum de rigueur permet ensuite
derrière d'avoir des bonnes performances
dernière question lonel je reviens vers
vous parce que ce ce choix il est quand
même pas Odin de de choisir un un staff
comme ça à trois têtes les deux fils et
le père je sais que vous connaissiez un
petit peu les membres qui sont aussi des
membres du club depuis longtemps ça ça a
été important dans votre décision
eu je dois avouer
qu'effectivement je te l'ai dit tout à
l'heure Anthony Guillaume je l'ai connu
il était haut comme ça donc
effectivement ça crée ça crée des liens
Christian est un est un ami mais il faut
savoir que j'ai proposé à Guillaume de
reprendre l'entraînement et d'ailleurs
de de reprendre l'entraînement en
association avec un un entraîneur qui
était déjà en place et que Guillaume m'a
proposé son projet et ce projet-l il
passait par effectivement la la
complicité la complicité familiale sans
doute et la complicité surtout
rugbistique qui existe dans la famille
païen parce que c'est une famille a
d'autres c'est une famille de rugby et
j'ai pas pu résister à cette à cette
invitation à suivre Guillaume dans son
choix donc j'ai respecté son son choix
je j'en suis aujourd'hui tout à fait
satisfait Guillaume a raison de dire
qu'il va travailler par palier c'estd
que le premier palier c'est
effectivement une victoire à domicile ou
à extérieur j'aime beaucoup cette
démarche là dans le club c'est aussi un
petit peu comme ça que j'envisage de de
faire les choses effectivement très bien
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
passés sur le setut sport et puis donc
premiers éléments de réponse pour ce
renouveau à la rentrée et cette
prochaine saison qui qui promet beaucoup
au Sky rugby merci beaucoup à tous les
deux dans 3 jours sera donné vous le
savez très certainement le coup d'envoi
du 98e alstum Open de France au Golf
National l'heure est est au dernier
réglage sur un parcours qui sera plus
spectaculaire cette saison en vue de la
rider Cup 2018 déjà image de Jonathan
vinman les tendes du village sont en
place l'arrosage automatique fonctionne
à plein régime à quelques jours du coup
d'en voie de l'Alstom Open de France les
effectifs ont été multipliés par deux
pour tailler les derniers centimètres de
gazon nous l'équipe de terrain on
travaille à 200 personnes parce qu'on
n'a pas des joueurs donc on peut faire
des bruits avec notre machine on peut
traverser un fairway il faut pas
regarder à de côtés on sait qu'il y a
pas aucun jouur et c'est notre niveau de
travail depuis une semaine le parcours
est fermé au public l'objectif le
laisser respirer et revêtir sa robe
finale pour le début de la compétition
en vue de la rider Cup 2018 quelques
évolutions ont été apporté à l'Albatros
en 2014 les Green seront plus denses et
les zones de Ruf mieux taillées est de
faire
mélange RA plus dur greens plus ferme et
plus rapide ça va vraiment compliqué
arrêter la B sur C greens on va vraiment
avoir spectacle avec plus de 50000
spectateurs l'an passé l'Alstom Open de
France sera aussi la fête du golf pour
les visiteurs des concours de sortie de
bunker seront notamment organisés en
parallèle de la compétition et pour les
professionnels premier swing prévu le 3
juillet et pour succéder au
nordirlandais mdell français seront
nombreux sur le fer West cette année 25
exactement avec en chef de fil le
nouveau prodige du golf tricolore Victor
dubisson actuellement 21e joueur mondial
il sera notamment accompagné de Thomas
Levet vainqueur en 2011 de l'Open de
France ou encore romain Vatel mais le
grand favori reste le récent vainqueur
de l'US Open l'Allemand Martin
keer pour sa deuxème manche le Fit Days
2014 ce étap à 50 ans en Evelin ce
weekend et si les spectateurs ont pu
assister au triomphe des triathlète de
Saint-Quentin ce Tour National de
triathlon permet également aux amateurs
de côtoyer les meilleurs mondiaux de la
discipline reportage réalisé avec Hod Mo
si dans le parc à vélo les élites se
préparent au départ de la course avec
leur routine habituelle cette fois-ci il
cohabite avec des dizaines de
triathlètes amateurs venus se confronter
au meilleurs Cynthia participe à son
premier trithnon et prend peu à peu ses
repères on sent que ils ont
l'habitude ça fait ouais ça fait pro
quoi c'est pas pour rien ça s'est fait
petit à petit en demandant des conseils
à droite à gauche et tout ça pour la
plupart ces passionnés viennent de la
course à pied et ont basculé sur le
triathlon pour varier les efforts de son
côté sifan est venu sur le Fit Days pour
prendre du plaisir on est tellement loin
d'eux que finalement c'est pas c'est pas
ça qui va nous qui va nous faire avancer
sur la course mais après c'est toujours
sympa de les côtoyer effectivement au
départ après on les voit plus trop les
premières coulées les triathlètes de 50
ans en line Fred mobre en tête mènent le
pleoton après les 20 km de vélo à
travers la vallée de Chevreuse le trio
belobre Pétel le brun entre dans la zone
de transition ensemble mais à la sortie
les premières foulées sont difficile
pour le jeune Emeric PEL qui cédera peu
à peu du terrain pour conserver sa 3è
place au final Fred Belaubre et Aurélien
le brin termineront ensemble ce Fit Days
après 1h3 d'effort le parcours était
vraiment sélectif en plus il y avait de
la pluie donc voil la partie vélo était
quand même assez à gérer et bon on'en
est bien sorti on se sent souten un peu
plus que d'habitude alors on avait envie
l'ascenseur et pu faire vibrer un pe les
SPECT près de 40 minutes plus tard après
avoir vu l'abandon de cyth sur ce
mécanique coupe la ligne d'arrivée
plutôt
satisfait plus libéré parce que je l'ai
vu arriver avec la voiture b bon est là
au MO et du coup voilà on prend plus de
plaisir on a même pas senti laav le
parcours en fait je connaissais pour
avoir fait quelques sorties en Val
Chevreuse et il est sympa il est sympa
en plus on a eu le soleil pendant le
vélo donc sympa
ouais chez les femmes cette deuxème
étape du feed day il a donn lieu à un
duel épique vous allez le voir les deux
championnes yelinoises Charlotte Morel
du club de 50 ans en Eveline et Julie
gigot de Versailles triathlon se sont
livrés un apre combat et si après la
natation la cinquantinoise était en tête
la versaillaise repasse devant sur le
vélo au prix d'un superbe effort pour
finalement terminer avec 26 secondes
d'avance sur Charlotte Morel Julie gigot
remporte donc cette deuxème étape du FED
days mais au classement par équipe c'est
Saint-Quentin qui s'impose grâce
notamment au triplet des hommes nous en
parlions la semaine dernière avec nos
invités sur la précédente édition du 78
sport le Feld day c'est également
l'occasion pour les enfants de découvrir
la discipline du triathlon grâce à un
village d'animation les futurs champions
ont pu s'essayer ce dimanche matin au
vélo et à la natation en combinaison
comme les professionnels l'année passée
environ 10 % des enfants participants
sur le Fit Days ont pris une licence par
la suite je vous en parlais tout à
l'heure au début de cette émission vous
le savez c'est à l'heure actuelle le 8e
de finale tant attendu entre la France
et le Nigéria et pour l'instant la
France tient le match nul la mi-temps
vient de se terminer Olivier vous êtes
sur place dans un bar à voisin
lebretonneux quelle est
l'ambiance oui anon nous sommes dans un
pb à voisin le Bretonneux pour l'instant
0-0 la mi-temps est pas encore tout à
fait terminée je peux vous dire qu'ici
c'est extrêmement tendu parce que les
nigérian nous donnent du fil à retord
mais les Français réagissent et ont
aussi des occasions alors j'ai à mes
côté Paty Paty supportrice des Bleus
toutes de tricolore vêtu paaty c'est
comment l'ambiance ici ben une super
ambiance mais on sent les gens endu
parce que bah ils arrivent pas à marquer
mais je pense qu'ils dominent et puis
ils vont y arriver allez les bleus j'y
crois c'est bon c'est sur le bon chemin
vous avez l'habitude des ambiances
justement ici dans ce pub par rapport à
d'habitude c'est comment alors le match
contre la Suisse évidemment ils sont
marqué 5-0 donc il y avait une ambiance
de fou et on avait cru d'ailleurs on
avait gagné la Coupe du monde alors là
il faut absolument qui marque là merci
beaucoup Paty merci beaucoup Paty et à
mes côté encore un supporter k k bonjour
comment vous l'avez vécu cette première
mitemps ici au pub bien pour l'instant
je dirais que on va passer mais en
prolongation principalement on va passer
en prolongation je pense
donc on verra bien quoi c'est tendu he
les Nigérians nous donne vraiment du f
c'est un peu tendu mais je pense qu'on
va passer ça va aller ça va aller rester
confiant tout simplement quoi voilà
comme le dit faut rester confiant Antony
et ici je peux vous dire il y a une
vraie tension mais les gens malgré tout
continuent à y croire comme vous l'avez
vu avec co comme vous l'avez vu avec
Paty et on est prêt pour la deuxème
mi-temps pour mettre l'ambiance merci
merci Olivier vous êtes en direct d'un
bar de voisin le Bretonneux avec à au
côté Jonathan villman on va suivre cela
de près au cas où s'il y a un but
n'hésitez pas intervenir comme chaque
année le vetatlon de l'amical police et
l'en cours rouiller a réuni les
policiers du Sud des Yvelines au bassin
de la Courance à Mor pas si cour à pied
VTT et grosse chaleur étaient au
rendez-vous il on faire un cocktail
assez détonnant aux spectateurs
l'émotion était également présente pour
cette 10e et dernière édition reportage
réalisé avec Olivier Manis calco et
Patrick Jacques de dixm 3,8 km de course
à pied 18 de VTT plus de ,6 km à nouveau
en basket pour terminer le tout sous un
soleil de plomb pour cette nouvelle
édition au bassin de la Courance à repa
le vetathlon de l'Amicale police et l'
enc embouillé n'a pas ménagé les
organismes à l'image du visage marqué du
vainqueur Vincent Poirier qui a 6
minutes près égalé le record de la
course 1h 11 minutes tout de même pour
le policier habitué des triathlon ça
s'est bien passé première course à pied
c'est plutôt mon domaine donc j'ai j'ai
pris un peu d'avance et à VTT j'étais
bien j' goostau dans les bosses ça allit
assez dur quand même il quand même assez
chaud il y av pas trop d'air à part la
partie VTT ù s en forêt donc ça va ça
passe mais à pied c'est vrai que c'est
c'est vraiment dur si la chaleur
étouffante augmentait la difficulté du
parcours les coureurs pouvaient compter
sur le soutien du public seul point noir
dans cette journée cette 10e édition du
vetathlon est aussi la dernière la
course souffre de la diminution du
nombre de participants en moyenne une
centaine sur les neuf premières éditions
les coureurs étaient environ 40 cette
année la faute également à une nouvelle
réglementation en forêt l'Office
National des Forêts donc interdit les
courses de VTT chronométré donc bon il
restructurent un petit peu chez eux et
forcément B nous on applique à la lettre
les conditions et le code des forêts
donc l'année prochaine on ne pourra plus
faire de courses VTT au sein des forêts
dominienes un nouveau challenge sportif
pourrait voir le jour dès l'an prochain
remplacement du vetatlon du tir combiné
à de la natation et de la course le
projet est déjà dans les cartons
allez on passe à l'essentiel des
résultats du
weekend en baseball pour le compte de la
10e et dernière journée du championnat
de Division 2 Montini recevait l'équipe
du pôle fédéral mais dans le premier
match du matin les cougards s'inclineent
9 points à 7 avant de relever la tête et
prendre la manche de l'après-midi 10 à 7
grâce à cette 14e victoire de la saison
les joueurs d'Alexandre on conclut la la
saison sur à une très belle 2e place et
se tourne désormais vers les play-offs
fin août ce weekend la colline
d'élancour j'en parlais dans les titres
accueillit la 15e édition de la
revanchearde 6e et dernière étape du VTT
tour ils étaient près de 160 à défier
les énormes pourcentages et Len courtois
mais dès les premières pentes Morgan
shedum attaque sur la première bosse
celui qui a fait partie un des 15
meilleurs pilotes au championnat de
France de cycl cross la saison passée
ensuite face facilement creuser l'écart
et gérer son effort en fin de course et
au passage de la ligne d'arrivée le
cycliste originaire d'Aubergenville
s'est même permis de porter à bout de
bras son VTT après plus d'une heure et
demi d'effort sur le point culminant
d'Île-de-France c'est vrai que c'était
un circuit assez gras moi j'aime bien
les circuits gras et puis il y avait pas
mal de difficultés en dév les côtes ça
glissaient pas mal et tout à la fin on
montait à pied certaines côte donc c'est
vrai que je suis un petit peu habitué à
ce type d'effort parce que je suis cycl
Crossman de base tout de suite j'ai vu
que j'avais fait l'écart donc après j'ai
j'ai descendu les dents pour essayer de
de vraiment creuser et puis bah c'est le
cas donc nickel ce weekend la 3è édition
du tournoi 7 de cœur se tenait à
Versailles cette année 25 équipes allant
de la fédéral 3 la ProD2 étit présente
au stade Porsche fontaine pour
s'inscrire chaque équipe devait apporter
un minimum de 800 € et tenez-vous bien
au total près de 30000 € ont été récolté
au profit de six associations comme
syndrome kabuki ou encore crristo rugby
adapté pour soulever des fonds au profit
de ces six associations caritatives vous
allez le voir certaines équipes ont
redoublé d'imagination sur les réseaux
sociaux comme ils ont eux pas la chance
et nous on peut leur si on peut leur
leur partager le plaisir qu'on peut nous
avoir sur le terrain c'est c'est génial
juste avoir un sourire leur donner un
sourire ou voilà juste un geste amical
leur serrer la main c'est c'est énorme
quoi donc nous nous on est on dit oui
tout de suite quoi chaque personne qui
devait collecter devait se filmer en
train de donner sur le site et à leur
tour de nominer trois personnes qui
devaient collecter au même moment en
fait on a joué sur le buzz où les mecs
faisaient le même jeu en picolant et
nous on a fait le même jeu sur les dons
sur un T sur le plan sportif vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué c'est la sélection
île-de-fance qui a remporté cette 3è
édition du tournoi 7 de cœur allez pour
finir des nouvelles de nos ramurs
yvelinois après 3 semaines de cour sur
la guit Pacific CCE Christophe papillon
et Clément IOT originaire de mmont dans
les Yvelines Contin continuent leur
travail aversé de l'océan Pacifique à la
RAM ils maintiennent leur 5e position
classement général derrière quatre
équipages composés de quatre rameurs et
surtout ils mènent la flotte toujours
des bateaux avec deux rameurs ces
derniers jours ils ont pu ramer sous le
soleil pour une fois et ils arrivent
même à suivre les exploit de l'équipe de
France de football grâce au mail qu'on
leur envoie je vous le rappelle leur
challenge est gigantesque puisqu'ils
doivent relier à la rame et sans escale
la Californie à Hawaï soit environ un
vol d'oiseau
3900 km c'est la fin de ce 78 sport
merci de l'avoir suivi excellente soirée
sur TVfil et allez les
[Applaudissements]
bleus